there are hollywood premieres and then
there are tom cruise premieres
welcome to entertainment tonight once
again tom has proven that when it comes
to promotion in red carpets he is
literally
the top gun the man's unmatched she
really is no show has more history with
tom and top gun and now we have come
full circle because e.t was his very
first stop clearing the runway for
maverick's big return
[Applause]
first of all that epic arrival that you
had come on tom that's fun there's only
one of those guys and here he comes the
best
[Applause]
from his action star entrance to this
military flyover look at that
tom's global premiere on the uss midway
was a full throttle spectacle this is
quite a moment it's been 36 years for
this film the fans have been asking for
it all around the world
okay question is where are you piloting
the helicopter not today i do fly that
helicopter but not today identify it you
know there were so many beautiful
moments in the film that i loved um but
i think the most beautiful were the
scenes with you and val you know the
first one i really rallied hard for him
to make the movie you're everyone's
problem and the kind of talent that he
has
and you see that scene it's very special
this is very special
what made you know also that you had to
go get gaga for this
till song end
she wrote the score and it was a moment
for all of us when she came in and sent
the song and i called her like
you just
you're amazing thank you this is our
movie
maverick of course is is a guy that
pushes the limits he always goes like
you say go to the line he goes right
over the line push i'm saying just a
little bit if i'm being honest i see a
little bit of that in tom cruise
it's daunting and there's not one person
in this movie and it wasn't sweating
bullets and i said you know what if
you're not sweating bullets making this
film you shouldn't be on this movie
top gun maverick blasts into theaters
may 27th the premiere was a special kind
of date night for the stars including
jennifer connelly who plays tom's love
interest she brought husband paul
bettany and 24 year old son kai dugan i
wanted to have my honey by my side and
kai lives in los angeles so it was a
you know great opportunity to see him
that's my girlfriend anna we've been
together for some time now it's nice to
be on an aircraft carrier with a nice
young lady like that who'd you bring
with you tonight it's a huge night oh my
god i brought my parents i brought my
grandparents from my wife's parents
brought a bunch of my boys from florida
it's uh it's a nice medley did you bring
your wife
did i not mention her and we'll edit
that and i started with my wife
i am still on a high from that
spectacular the cast brought everybody
with them mamas daddies wives cousins
uncles next door neighbors they waited
long enough nobody was missing that and
by the way kev a little tc fun fact this
is the longest gap between films for tom
cruise of his entire career his last
film was 2018's mission impossible
fallout